basic scherz ja heute servus und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
es ist ein verregneter vergammelter
sonntag bei mir hier unten ich war
gestern abend feiern ich saß auf meinem
bett total über klatsch wieder das
vielleicht kennt nach dem feiern hat
mich gefragt ob er was für video kann
ich heute hochladen das mir eingefallen
dass irgendeiner von mir mal die
kommentare geschrieben hatte hsg machst
du eigentlich deine haare macht doch mal
dein video darüber aber ich dachte mir
ist eigentlich ganz gute idee war ja
auch sehr viele geschrieben haben dass
die häufig besser gefallen als sie davor
hatte die seien so ausgezehrt videos war
genau so wie es mir vorgestellt habe ich
meine absolute katastrophe ich weiß
nicht was mich damals geritten hat aber
jetzt sind die so und deswegen machen
wollte ganz billiges homevideo konnte
aus meinem zimmer aus meinem bart mit
erotische dusch kern mit erotischer
fanpage vor in deutschland so noch nicht
gegeben eine milliarde likes und ich
mache das hier nie wieder genau warum
zuschauer
schritt nummer eins duschen
ich hoffe dass die kamera wasserdicht
ist nicht nur deutlich hat sich aber
normalerweise des russischen olympischen
weniger auf tour habe ich meinen
jüngsten gesichter für euch wer nicht
eigentlich schon mal beim duschen
gesehen ich kann gerade niemanden denken
der menschen gesehen
locker mal hier was die dümmsten
gesichter zeit und ich sehe dass du
jetzt stellte der senior all die jahre
habe ich so komische presse gezogen
der zweite teil dieses unfassbar
bereichen tutorials heute ihr werden
sohn einfach nicht drauf gekommen
haare abtrocknen wenn die
gesichtsausdrücke nicht in diesem video
gemacht habt offenen skala von 1 bis 10
c bis maximal der rote lines es einfach
nur knapp zwei tage negativ angeblich
mehr so jetzt leute ich weiß ich mit
euch wird echt viel zu aber teil 3
niemand niemand mehr so oft halter
gekommen war gefüllt
ok jetzt sehen meine haare aus wien
kennt nicht vorläge gefühlt so flauschig
und objektiven so jackman
okay leute jetzt schritt 4 dafür einfach
keine ahnung was auf meine arbeit
benutzen was ich gerade tue ich habe mir
von einer weile mal dass die gekauften
meldung zu heißt es ist ganz in ordnung
ist ok rich ganz geil ist sowieso das
beste daran arbeitet auch schweineteuer
ich hab damals 18 euro was dürfen die
scheiße die zahl generell friseure
zocken apple so hat man so was ich würde
ich sagen dass man so was unbedingt
braucht das zeug gibt aber auch bei
amazon david mynall inc und
entscheidungen stellen
auf jeden fall hinter der ungefähr so
viel und jetzt was ich früher gemachten
fehler hat mir gesagt ich soll dir die
haare klappt dann in den verteiler leute
vorher gemacht ich war zum mittel
sondern von vereinsseite erst in der
hand der service so wenn es dann hätten
vorgehabt die haare also quasi alle
sportlichen seitwärts komplett
management dann sieht ungefähr so aus
dann könnt ihr die ganze sache jetzt
deine könnte ich zum beispiel das
einhorn machen
sehr beliebt bei den frauen aus ihrem
mache ich kann alles und packst du hier
rüber nach rechts wenn es bei mir alles
wartet auf die seite wie ein bisschen
vorne machst du bist in und hier hinten
habe ich einfach so ein wirbel da muss
doch noch drücken das ist nicht so krass
abstellte und was ihr dann versuchen
sollte was ich dafür suche ist diese
dieses überstehen dann direkt versucht
nach hinten zu packen das haut aber in
der regel mit haar wachsen
nicht so wirklich ich mach so rutschte
dabei
deswegen nimmt er einfach gefragt und
bei euch dass ihr seid ich traue
kompletten zeit nicht reif und dann
einfach nach hinten voll nach hinten
holen dann sieht man auch schon es wird
schon besser steht nicht mehr so krass
ab beziehungsweise steht gar nicht mehr
ab nur noch da hinten so kaum fehler
aber das okay denn vor aussteht auf v
man einfach die fordern hoch den
november so mitte und hinten seitlich
rüber mit ihr vorne
es kam mir vor als würde irgendwas mach
ein bisschen qualm aber packend ja
scheiße ich werde er das bisschen
verstört ist deswegen meist einfach so
also später vorm haus ein bisschen rock
über pop und jahre läuft so mache ich
meine haare ihr solltet euch auf jeden
fall raus geht nach klamotten anziehen
heute meinte man euch seht ihr das
andere vorausgeht und denkst du